♪ ♪ ♪
- C'est notre survie qui est
en jeu en ce moment.
- Brûler des forêts pour de
la viande, c'est dégueulasse.
- Je souhaite des changements
radicaux de la part
des gouvernements.
- Maintenant, on va regarder
qu'est-ce que la désobéissance
civile, OK?
- Une vingtaine de militants
écologistes sacrifient
un beau samedi de septembre
pour apprendre l'abc
de la désobéissance civile
non violente.
PHILIPPE DUMONT, formateur
en désobéissance civile,
Extinction Rebellion
- La désobéissance civile
envoie le message suivant :
la situation est rendue
à ce point grave que je ne peux
pas rester inactif et malgré
les risques et les dangers,
je décide de commettre
de la désobéissance civile
et d'assumer les conséquences
de mes gestes.
- La formation est offerte
par Extinction Rebellion.
Le groupe, créé en
Grande-Bretagne il y un an,
a maintenant des filiales
dans une cinquantaine de pays.
Ses membres font des coups
d'éclat comme bloquer des ponts
ou l'accès à des magasins bon
marché. Ils se rebellent contre
l'économie de surconsommation
qui est en train d'étouffer
la planète, selon eux.
RONALD DAIGNEAULT
- Le leitmotiv des
gouvernements, c'est de pousser
l'économie plus loin qu'on est
déjà là, et on est déjà trop
loin. Je vais avoir l'impression
de voter pour le moins pire.
ALYSSA BERRIS
- Je vais voter pour
le groupe... le parti politique
qui va avoir les mesures
les plus entreprenantes et
qui... avec qui je vais avoir
confiance que les actions vont
suivre les paroles.
- C'est la question embêtante.
Pour qui je vais voter, ça,
je l'ai pas encore décidé, mais
la question environnementale,
elle est centrale à mon choix
- Comme bien des écologistes,
Philippe Dumont ne pardonne pas
aux libéraux l'achat du pipeline
Trans Mountain dans l'ouest.
Le groupe Extinction Rebellion
n'appuiera aucun parti,
mais compte se faire entendre
durant la campagne électorale.
- Il faudrait décarboniser
l'économie pour 2025. C'est
très, très court, et il y a
aucune plateforme qui prône ça.
- Catherine Bouchard-Tremblay
est une des porte-parole
du groupe. Comme les autres
rebelles, elle croit
que l'urgence justifie
la désobéissance civile.
CATHERINE BOUCHARD-TREMBLAY,
p.-parole, Extinction Rebellion
- La désobéissance civile, c'est
pointer le problème puis dire
comme : "Là, on n'a plus le
temps, gang. Il faut juste
changer le système, là."
- Action!
(tumulte)
- L'exercice met en scène
des militants qui bloquent
l'accès à un site d'exploitation
pétrolière et des travailleurs
qui tentent de passer.
- Deux heures dans le trafic
juste pour m'en venir puis tu me
laisses pas passer. Laisse-moi
donc passer. Ça va prendre
deux minutes.
- Ils apprennent à résister
aux provocations.
- Je suis entrée dans un jeu,
là t'sais, j'essayais d'être
provocante, tout ça, ça fait
que j'avais un rôle, mais
rapidement, par sa voix,
son calme, ça m'a vraiment
comme déstabilisée.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Ces jeunes manifestent pour
dénoncer les feux de forêts
en Amazonie.
- On a choisi, dans le fond,
de faire du faux sang, tout
à partir de matières végétales,
pour s'en enduire les mains,
pour symboliser tout le drame
que vivent les communautés
là-bas.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Coups d'éclat, désobéissance
civile, ils sont prêts à faire
bien des sacrifices pour
sauver la planète et mettre
les politiciens face
à leurs responsabilités.
OLIVIA RUGE
- Pas juste des contrats comme
l'Accord de paris qui a jamais
été respecté, mais des actions
concrètes pour réduire
la pollution.
LÉO DUMARESQ-BOUCHARD
- Ça veut dire limiter
les grandes industries, limiter
la déforestation, commencer
à planter. Oui, c'est dur, oui,
ça va nuire à notre confort
pour un moment, pour un certain
moment, mais c'est nécessaire,
c'est des sacrifices qui doivent
être faits.
ALEXIE WOLF
- Ces sacrifices-là, oui,
les adultes peuvent nous dire :
"Ah! Mais qu'est-ce que vous
faites à manquer l'école tous
les vendredis? Votre éducation
est tellement importante pour
votre futur! Mais quel futur
si on n'en a même pas?!